hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar use visualization to
boost your precision medicine research
i'm julie O'Rourke of lab routes and
I'll be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
science fit collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by Cukor
Lucar omics explore is a DIY next
generation bioinformatics
software for research and life science
plant and biotech industries as well as
academia the powerful visualization
based data analysis tool with inbuilt
powerful statistics delivers immediate
results and provides instant exploration
and visualization of big data to learn
more visit wwm let's get started
you can pose questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them into the drop down box located on
the far left of your screen labeled ask
a question and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the answer question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits have located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker carl johan
Iverson president of Clue core carl
johan Iverson has been the clew core
president for 10 years and has more than
20 years experience in the software
industry spanning areas from development
to business management and sales in
Sweden and abroad Col Johann Iverson
will now begin his presentation
okay thank you for the introduction
visualization
driven data analyses have many benefits
as you can see and you can immediately
start to go Confucians
based on a visualization as the one that
is rotating in front of you the user can
see what is happening and control the
analysis through all steps this includes
quality and enables better and more
actionable results
today's webinar will be very visual and
I will demonstrate Blyth using through
Chrome Explorer to do that I will share
my screen as I do now and I will switch
between slides and alive software
demonstration this the objectives are to
show you how you can understand more
about visualization in combination with
interactive filters and how that enables
deeper insights so large and complex
data heads
to learn more about our visualization
trade and data analysis which uses the
risk of errors and makes it easy to
detect batch effects and outliers
understand why visualization is
important in precision medicine and
diagnostics
but before we start with the
visualization and the demonstration I
would like to tell you a little bit more
about cube core
the clue core clue finding the clue to
to the core helping you the users to
understand more about your data
were founded in Sweden which is in
Northern Europe in 2007 the ideas
originates from learned University
during the law 10 years the company has
developed significantly and now have
clients in 25 countries and can list
more than 600 articles intuitive
journals that refers to to core 29 of
them are nature journals we currently
ship two new product releases every year
and have done more than ten releases
into thought
head offices in Sweden and we also have
an office in New York there are native
solutions both for Windows and Mac users
you
most well-known universities use Google
you can see a list of some well-known
Union customers in the u.s. above or in
front of you and you probably recognize
the majority of them three out of five
of the Lord is former company for
customers and the long list of smaller
former biotech companies as well as the
universities in Europe's have defined in
the bottom their Oxford Institute the
King's College Caroline scan so on and
so
a clerk or we always put visualization
in the center additional statistics and
methods are normally very table based as
you can see to your left then in this
case you can generate a picture in the
end we do it the other way around you
always start with the visualization
only work with this allocation is not
enough you have to combine that with
interactivity and ease-of-use to create
useful solutions that delivers
actionable results that also can be
easily shared with colleagues and other
user groups
the main result of using clear core is
that we get the possibility to create
better and more actionable results this
is achieved by taking advantage of the
benefits which are very easy to use
you never maybe have done a few mouse
clicks to sort them and quite advanced
analysis and we will always get a visual
feedback 78% of our use of state in
customer service that Google makes
Explorer is easy or even very easy to
use you get as I said always additional
feedback so you know what you do and you
know what actions you have taken
the visualization think you are
extremely fast so that makes it possible
for you to catch many ideas and you also
get that interactivity if you compare
for instance the principal component
analysis close PCA which I will show you
more about later it is many many times
faster than all other software solutions
the underlying software architecture is
very generic we have an assumption free
analysis it built in and if that this is
enough you can expand the program both
with our and scripts in Python
you can work with a very broad range of
omics and NGS data here are a number of
examples and both for the measurements
and and of course also for annotations
and we support a wide range of recording
industry standard file formats
that was a short introduction to Cukor
and qmx explorer but now let's have a
look into precision medicine one way of
approaching a precision medicine project
is shown above there are three phases
temporal is the possibility to group and
classify patients into well-defined
subgroups
during the innovation and development
phase focuses on understanding more
about subgroups and developing a
solution that is based on the
combination of drugs and diagnostics
tests as we move forward in time the
diagnosis tests shall be applied and
results delivered from labs to the
physicians it grow in complexity and
panel based tests the need for clear
communication methods increase the third
phase is to present findings to the
patient and discuss treatment options
let me show how this might look in the
future
in a short while
visualization we play a world in all
phases but it will differ in the live
demonstrations later I will show you
visualization for the third phase but
before that I would like to show you
some ideas on how you might look in the
last phase
so here you see how it might look when a
doctor meets a patient and visualize the
outcome on the Diagnostics tests as you
can see there that is the patient that
now belongs to the yellow subgroup and
we need to find a treatment to manage
the disease that the patients are
suffering for when we know which group
the individual belongs to it's about
managing the treatment trajectory moving
the patient from the yellow group to the
green group of healthy individuals and
this is how that could be visualized to
the patient
you
okay sorry that that brings me to going
back from the patient and the third
phase of a precision medicine project to
the first station face and actually
start to look at how software it can
help you in defining some good so the
first demonstration will show how you
quickly and easy can do an initial
inspection of a data set and how that
can be verified towards known annotation
I will show you multiple visualizations
and filters and also give you some ideas
on how medicalization can save God from
missing important aspects of your data
set so now I will switch here and - and
a few chromic explorer which you have in
front of you
I have already lovely the data set and I
have noted the so called PCI plot
in this case there are 132 samples each
clear represents one patient in this
example it's a patient who have leukemia
the three principle components here is a
way of reducing the dimensionality of
this large data set there are 13,000 256
genes that are measured so if you would
print this in Excel it would be like
some around 4,000 pages so that gives
you the size of the table or the metrics
that we are managing
into the analysis and exploration let me
just give you some short introduction to
the user interface here you control a
lot of the actions with a pointer and as
you can see I can rotate I can select
the label something and I do it like
that and the labeling works both in
tables and applause
and clear that here is to the left here
there are four tabs sample tab will
include information about annotations
sample annotations this is where they
are imported or loaded the variable
collected variable lists that can be
generated or imported the log tab here
tells you exactly what calculations that
has been done to the data set and the
NGS tab is for filters when you are
working with NGS data this window here
includes the statistical filters that
you can use the variant filtering here
and a different type of a novelty tests
are available here and the extension
here is for extensions out to all you
select the prototypes appear and there
is a quite a long range of different
plots that you can select from and we
will start to use the PCA plot and some
of the tools I will tell you a little
bit more as we work out way through this
data set but I believe you have the
basics now
you
so we would expect to see subgroups in a
in a dataset and if it's a leukemia but
we are not seeing anything and that is
because so if noise in the data and we
need to manage that noise in some way
and variance filtering is a good tool to
do that
and what we will do now is to remove
variables by the filtering of variants
so the variables with the smallest
variance will be removed here and as you
see this is really the unique feature or
one of the unique features could go
getting soft and interactive response to
your actions exactly I told you earlier
and
can always discuss how much you should
filter and that depends on what type of
objective you have in this case we are
going to look for subgroups so something
that gives me a clear view there is also
metric here Corp reaction score which I
will not go into deeper but green means
that the visualization that you are
looking at is a good representation of
the data sets if we look here in the TC
april's we can clearly see that there
are seem to be structure there is one
group over here there is one here one
here then there are a couple of samples
here in the middle which may be their
own group or do they belong to this
group over here that is not easily
decided at at this point and this is
typically what I meant earlier with that
you get the deeper insights into the
data just by looking at it either also a
possibility to detect like batch effect
because if this was a batch effect if
you for instance have an annotation
describe an updated e4 from a different
geographical position or a different lab
so you will clearly see that directly
now what do you do when you have
identified that group yeah we create an
annotation give it a couple of values
color it and then we are going to
annotate those samples here and this is
how is it is done you should pointer few
mouse clicks and we are now divided over
yourself into groups to learn more about
this Lord it will appear we can
temporarily remove those samples and in
queue code you don't have to restore
anything you can just click that group
and they are removed another back if you
look down to the left here then you will
see that there is only one on 18 samples
left and now we are back to this one on
a 32
so let's see did that make it a little
bit clearer
yep there is one navigate
you
then to get more information in him you
can connect the nearest neighbors and
then we see
we can collect up group
and if we bring it back
if the
Jenica whether to do with us for that I
observed earlier and you can see there
are probably more groups here
one way of them continuing would be to
do the same thing to remove all the
three groups and then dig deeper into
the rest of the data set and can do the
things that one more group here is it so
clear
but you can also try to use other plot
types so one of the options that we have
is T's new plots so if we
updated 50 prop unfortunately it's not
possible to make that completely
interactive since it's quite extremely
expensive calculations with so so it has
to be a couch butter for that one but
you can see the patterns are very
similar the groups that I identify with
PCA and you also get help to identify
some of the other groups and then you
can also see there are samples that you
can start to think about this is the
right group so on and the four ones are
still here in in the in the middle
and we can
of course annotate also in this plot so
if we
take those for your stuff we have that
information now we can go back to the
PCA plot
and let's see then what we have found
one way of doing that is to compare with
existing annotations if you have that so
let's create so-called synchronize plots
where you have all the same calculations
being applied to the data set but you
can have different annotations and there
is an annotation here called leukemia
subtypes and
you see that we identify the yellow
group which is equal to this purple one
here PLMS we are densified that one over
here which is equal to the e to a PBX
one group and so on and so on but
and we have also identified for the
white group over here that is called a
totally other group and so on
so we found relevant results if the
conclusions and we did that very quickly
at the same time as we had good control
of the process this was a form of
supervised clustering whether individual
the user you are involved in deciding
clusters and with the court you can also
apply
and k-means clustering here is one
example so if I select like number
trustus seven I get the new annotation
and I can put up here
as you see we identify
people are good
so this is a way of verifying your
return so that's me
here
so to summarize demonstration one it was
quick to find structure and we have had
full control of the data through all the
steps and this enables the user to test
many more ideas in a given time do both
easier and about advanced analysis
without being an analysis expert and you
can utilize your domain knowledge for
deeper insights you can know things
about the specific sample so you can see
that in in the plots and what we have
seen when organizations increment the
use of procore they were all edges are
able to offer the analysis experts and
better questions
we move on move on here to demonstration
number two so back again to the program
soon and off to the demonstration even
know how visualization gives deep
insights into data and why it can be
very useful to combine visualization
with statistical tests you will also see
how an example how you quickly can
verify results in a second data set and
how easy it is to communicate without
using for instance of PCP
you
there we go so I would close
that one eat that one remove that
so whatever do now
I will
apply I show you the tableview so
this is how you could expect that it
looks in a table
and then we are going to do a test a
t-test statistical test - good
comparison
I use this annotation called the Kimia
subtype and I will get for da MLL group
towards all other samples
move this slider here
see how the number of variables goes
down so 295 and I will go down to 1/100
and I think
and we would like to store this result
of the discriminating variables you
screaming like a yeast and for that I
have a list that is already available
here that is updated when I change this
filter so if I change it it's there I
just make a copy of it
economically sound and then I can add
information like p-value for discovery
rate with the Q value and it's available
here as columns
so it looks very good and this is a
typical step that you could
do in in or any other software about
what what what can we see if we for
instance bring up the visualization
instead so let's show you another one
and with a heat map and I will get all
my samples and I we color it according
to the annotation we are working with
you
so there
you see that that all
can see things like this you can easily
see in the heat map that there is one
sample which is not very consistent that
comes from the green group but seems to
be very close to the blue group and that
gives you additional information which
you never find you don't have a chance
to fund up anything or by just looking
at the selected variables with the
lowest aq value you need some sort of
visualization to help you detect that
there is one sample here as we might
have to look a little bit closer to and
if you select the heat map or you select
the PCA
it doesn't really matter because you
will pick out at that specific example
even if we have selected one hundred and
eighty are both at the best or
separating these two groups these blue
samples from the others there are one
sample here that might need a closer
investigation and again if you will go
back to the Disney cause I'm quite sure
it will pop up here too
and it does so it's very useful
to use the visualization to complement
your statistical test
okay we have now pradana statistical
tests we have visualized we have learned
more dig deeper into the data and we
have a list of 100 most discriminating
genes that can separate this PL AML one
group from the others - that is it only
specific to this dataset or does it have
a broader meaning one of the very useful
tools into comics Explorer is that you
could download data from gene expression
omnibus in a very straightforward way so
here is another leukemia dataset that
someone some other group has done
I loaded it I have multiple data sets
open and
we can it's now on top on gene symbols
so I will have to adjust that and I can
do it in here now as soon have both my
data set on gene symbols so that I can
compare them then to see how my list 100
genes here and is performing or
affecting my new dataset I can just do
that and it seems to separate out the
subgroup here from from the others in
this data set and s try to see from the
annotation what that might mean it seems
like we have that list of 100 genes that
temp is 86 when it's gene symbols and
eighty six matches separates out these
yellow samples and let's see in the
annotation here what those on the T L AM
L 1 and if you remember that is the blue
group here that we actually created a
list for for and then there are some
others here interesting and then there
is the element 1 + hyper diploid e over
there so by a lot diffuse very sound
results and what we could have hoped for
and we have now verified the list
generated in the first date of it in a
second data set and done it in in a very
very short time
so to summarize demonstration two we
have this in less than ten minutes
found new results and visualize them we
have verified the findings in the second
dataset and during the steps we have
with the help of visualization being
able to have full control and actuals
have found some potential issues that we
need to address visualization driven
data analysis or precision medicine is
performed by individuals that is
biologists bioinformaticians and other
scientists but to secure high efficiency
the right shift up in an organization is
required to do that the following areas
need attention deployment and
customization
as example for that is that we have Mac
and Windows and we also have something
called templates where you can create
specific workflows for your organization
onboarding is always very very important
Kukui with the visualization is easy to
learn and there are also templates that
can be specific and used as a starting
point for learning in addition to
traditional learning material as videos
webinars documentation is all then a
learning and enhancing it's not only to
learn once but you also need to enhance
and expand your usage we're training
support concise events for large
organizations
let's now move into something that is
very hands-on in the aspect of precision
medicine we have now learned things
about our datasets and know them well
next step could be to actually build a
classifier and try on some samples to
see how it works in the end it is the
outcome of or precision medicine has to
be a drug or and diagnostics test to
come with it so that I switch back here
now I will close those data sets that
have you and bring in training data set
that would ever use a validation data
set
you
okay so now I have two data set open and
that is a good starting point if I'm
going to build a classifier and very
many times
it makes a lot of sense to reduce the
number of variables before a start so
and the variance is doing is again a
good point here to try to remove some
noise and exactly how much it will have
to be an iterative process but one way
is of course to use the visualization
and try to find a point where the stops
to be structure in the data set but
that's not a bad starting point and on
that then I go to this tab up here
called beam classifier and I get a
number of options
I can select different classifier
methods select support vector machine
then it's off to the key and I select
the leukemia subtype I can help the
classifier about ranking my samples and
then you can either build a built-in
user building cross-validation scheme or
you can use the validation data service
validation data set is too preferred so
selected
important here svm leukemia sub-tab
banking multi group comparison
validation data set is this one and the
validation key has the same name then i
press until
and a brood
- that's the name of the classifier that
I'm building and you will be presented
with a report feels about the classifier
where you can find a lot of parameters
for how the FN was constructed and you
will see the outcome and you can see we
classified everything perfect without
but one sample in the TL Hema one group
wasn't classified correctly in the in
the validation data set which yeah of
course we would have wished for accuracy
one and by tweaking changing parameters
and so on we could probably achieve it
but this is still a good classifier you
get information about tray the high
profile parameter that is used and
tested and you get a list of the
variables that is used in the classifier
so
and we are going to find out how it
actually works on a new data set so let
me clue minimize those and import a
third data set data exists
so here are a data sets with ten samples
and now I can apply that crazy
classifier to this and I get a new
annotation
can cow
accordingly and then if I take if we say
the truth then there were regional
classification of these and put up as
labels
we can see how we succeeded so if we
take the white one e to a PBX one
a good thing
maybe we'll call it coloring here
the ARL Piper deployed everything is as
we want it to be so with this loss step
have created a classifier we have tested
it evaluated it and and also run it on a
data set
which gives brings us to the end of the
demonstrations here and to summarize the
precision medicine promise requires
expanded measurements for drug
development and diagnostics to companion
new drugs visualization is a key tool to
improve precision medicine tires it
supports all the phases from innovation
to development and even to the going all
the way to the patient and with
visualization you will enable improved
results and new findings fewer mistakes
involvement of more scientists or
scientist groups and clear communication
both internally but also externally
cuckoo omics Explorer is available for a
free trial download so you can try it
yourself and but and which is something
we will recommend my demonstration here
is only stores the best thing is of
course to factor a p4 v with that we are
opening up for questions Thank You Karl
Johan for your presentation a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them into
the drop down box located on the far
left of your presentation window labeled
ask a question and click on the send
button Karl Johan Iverson will answer as
many questions as time permits the first
question is what type of classifiers do
you support
yes there are currently three
classifiers that we support support
vector machine random trees and KNN in
total for future we will also support so
called
excuse classifiers
thank you next question is is it
possible to integrate the program in a
workflow
yes so if you have workflows in your
organization that can that you're very
specific we have a functionality called
templates to support that where you on
the order organization can write scripts
in Python that then are executed in in
Cukor which makes it possible to do
maybe half of the steps that I have been
showing you here and then we get to a
point where you then can begin a
continue the analysis so the template is
and not the endpoint but the new
starting point
thank you next question is how easy is
it to get started yeah and I'd say if
you're a normal user of of software and
it probably takes you 1 or 2 hours to
get you well-acquainted with the program
and then you're up running so it's
really quick
great looks like we have time for one
more question and that will be can I try
it myself
yeah as you can see in front of you here
I guess that question came early so
download a free trial on koco.com and
try it and we will be happy to support
you doing that work
well I would like to once again thank
Karl Johan Iverson for his presentation
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank our
sponsor Cukor for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through September 2019
leverets will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye